- Oh, my God,
- Oh hi.
that's beautiful.
- Oh come on, thank you.
- I love the colors.
I was like you wear your colors today.
- Have we draped ourselves?
- I know we've
draped ourselves.
- There's the part
you sit down and you're like and drape.
- And drape.
So wait, you have a cool ritual though,
I know, about just relaxing
kind of de-stressing
which I think is awesome.
- Thank you very much.
It's a ritual.
It's better if you have
a grill or a backyard.
And right now I'm living in New York
so I haven't been able
to do it in a while.
But yeah, you know how life is life
and we all kind of get
overwhelmed sometimes.
And one of the things I like to do
is you light a candle,
set a timer for 12 minutes,
get some paper, a pen,
and then just write for 12 minutes.
And you don't even think about
what you're writing.
- Oh.
You don't even read it back.
And then at 12 minutes you stop the timer
and then you set the thing on fire.
- This sounds awesome.
(audience oohs and ahs)
- It's really great.
And there's just
something really wonderful
about taking all the stuff
that was making you so kind of worked up,
and off your center,
and destabilize that you
could probably scream
- Yeah.
and watching it
just turn into ash and
like turn into nothing.
It's really powerful.
- I love that.
I love the it turning into ashes thing,
that's nice.
- Yeah, it is.
- All right, well,
we're both gonna be-
- We're complicated creatures,
aren't we all?
- We are.
By the way, Alexis,
that was a beautiful story about your mom.
Thank you for sharing that.
- I know!
Thank you.
- I know and she looks
so beautiful today too.
- I mean, yeah,
(audience applauds)
what a great audience.
- So we're both turning
40 this year.
- We are both turning 40.
I'm excited.
Congratulations.
- Congratulations as well.
I know a lot of women in the
industry get weird about age.
I love it.
I feel like life gets, I don't know,
exponentially better every year.
- I get more comfortable every
year and I get more grateful.
And I feel like staying
grateful is getting easier.
And I think, I don't know,
I think that sometimes
a little bit of it is
I've always had friends-
I mean, you're probably the same way
being in the music industry.
You've had the opportunity to learn
from so many people that came before.
So I've always had friends
from older generations.
And so for me, aging never
seemed like a big deal
because I've always
had friends those ages.
But I have lost, or a
few friends have shifted,
and I realize that I'm
over the halfway point
if I go at the same point as them.
- Yeah.
- So the way I'm holding it is like,
oh yeah, you're turning 40.
You might be closer to the
end than the beginning.
Just get to the good stuff.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, I love that.
Get to the good stuff
'cause you don't know.
And like, come on.
I mean, the world is the world right now.
So if you have the
opportunity to choose joy
then I think we are obliged
to take it, frankly.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- Absolutely.
I love also that you said shifted
because I always think it's weird
how people are always like,
you know, friends,
there are seasons for some
relationships in our lives.
And I think that that's
important that that's okay.
So I like that you said shifted though,
that was really good
- Yeah,
how you said that.
I don't like
to say that they're lost.
And by the way,
I don't usually talk about
this stuff personally.
I think I'm turning red.
You're really good
at what you do.
- Oh.
But no, I like shifted because I don't-
- It's nice.
- I think it's softer and
to me it feels more honest.
- Yeah, absolutely.
And it's cool.
- Because that might not
be the end of the story.
We don't actually know.
- That's what I mean,
they're seasons.
Yeah, people do come and go.
And I think that that's
something I learned-
Actually, it's funny,
'cause you did say 'cause
I'm from the music industry,
just in the industry in general,
I think everybody,
there are literally so many
different types of ages.
Like there's so many
generations in what we do,
especially on tour.
So it's awesome.
I think you learn from all
of those different people
and I think that people
come and go and it's nice.
And you can still be
friends with those people
but it's just like a different season.
Anyway, I didn't even mean to go there.
So you did that to me.
(audience and Anne applaud)